les 27 pays de l'union européenne ont
accepté de reporter pour une troisième
fois la date de sortie du royaume uni
c'est maintenant prévue au plus tard le
31 janvier 2020 le premier ministre
boris johnson a déposé une motion pour
déclencher une élection aujourd'hui
votre qu'il a perdu il fallait quand
même les deux tiers de la chambre
il va déposer un projet de loi demain
pour la tenue d'élections où il n'aura
besoin que d'une simple majorité
le ribosome est professeur au
département de science politique de
l'université de montréal bon soir le
rideau d'eau mais qu'est ce qui se passe
maintenant que l'union européenne a
accepté de reporter au 31 janvier 2020
le brésil oui alors maintenant il faut
que le parlement britannique vote la loi
qui entérine l'accord qui a été conclu
entre l'union européenne et le premier
ministre britannique
du point de vue britannique et ensuite
il faudra que le parlement européen
ratifie l'accord à son tour mais ça sera
seulement dans un deuxième temps une
fois que le parlement britannique aura
adopté cette loi est donc entre tain le
premier ministre voudrait déclencher une
élection
oui parce qu'en fait il n'a pas de
majorité actuellement dans la chambre on
l'a vu d'ailleurs le vote de cet après
midi les deux tiers n'a pas été possible
pour lui il a encore essuyé un échec la
semaine dernière donc là il lui faut il
espère en fait avec de nouvelles
élections conquérir davantage de sièges
au parlement ce qui lui permettrait de
voter plus facilement là ce qu'on
appelle le wild bunch règlement qui la
loi qui entérine la sortie du royaume
uni pourquoi l'union européenne se
trouve ça acceptable de reporter à plus
tard pourquoi l'union a accepté ce
report qui voulue par le parlement par
monsieur johnson par le parlement
britannique
alors oui je pense que déjà le fait que
pour boris johnson ne souhaitait pas un
report ça certainement pesé dans ladite
dans la décision compris les 27 chefs
d'états membres et de gouvernement
pourquoi parce que cette fois ci on a
deal qui est soutenu par le premier
ministre c'était le cas aussi avec le
gouvernement de theresa may mais la
menace d'un break c'est 200 sans accord
était très forte notamment parce que
c'était la ligne dure tenu par boris
johnson alors que ce n'était pas celle
de theresa may auparavant donc
certainement cette pression là à jouer
l'autre l'autre dimension c'est que déjà
la semaine dernière les diplomates
européens ont fait passer le message que
à peu près tout le monde était d'accord
pour donner une extension la seule dans
le fond la seule capitale qui s'y
opposait c'était de la france voilà avec
l'idée que ça ne ferait que entretenir
l'incertitude donc le compromis qui a
été trouvé c'est un compromis
typiquement européen le conseil
fonctionne beaucoup par logique de
consensus
avec cette idée que c'est une flex
tention donc on a voilà le bric site a
jusqu'au 31 janvier pour se passer si le
royaume uni arrive à est prêt à sortir
avant avec le parlement qui adopte une
loi ça sera possible avant ouais ça
pourrait arriver donc avant le 31
janvier donc ce que nous avons
présentement c'est une entente avec
l'union européenne ce que nous pourrions
avoir dès demain c'est une élection le 9
ou le 12 décembre et à ce moment là tout
est possible encore mais on présume que
monsieur johnson s'il veut aller en
élections c'est qu'ils sentent qu'ils
auraient un plus grand pouvoir les
sondages sont de son côté là non oui
effectivement les sondages donnent le
les conservateurs avec une avance
néanmoins il les donne pas majoritaire
pour autant oui donc l'association
encore une fois comme avec tous les
épisodes du brésil depuis 2016
changeantes
surtout que les libéraux démocrates et
le snt ont fait en prime mandat de faire
campagne sur un nouveau référendum
donc ce ne sont pas les deux parties qui
obtiendrait la majorité des sièges loin
de là néanmoins ça pourrait faire
changer le cours de l'élection parce que
ces deux partis d'opposition voudrait
reposer la question britten ce sont deux
parties qui sont profondément pour le
remake plombé le maintien caen dans
l'union européenne effectivement et qui
ont gagné des voix au cours de ces deux
dernières
l'enjeu c'est l'irlande du nord vraiment
ce qui est au coeur de tous les débats
jusqu'à maintenant c'est vraiment la
frontière l'union douanière mais alors
j'ai envie de dire que c'est ce qui
reste c'est à dire qu'au coeur des
débats pendant les deux années
précédentes il y avait quand même
beaucoup d'autres choses que sur
lesquels le gouvernement britannique n'a
pas eu d'autre choix que de céder
notamment toutes les questions de normes
si jamais le royaume uni veut rester
enfin veut conclure un accord de libre
échange complet la frontière nord
irlandaise effectivement le dernier
écueil qui reste hélas le l'accord
conclu par boris johnson représente le
dissident font la différence majeure
qu'il y avait avec l'accord précédent
conclu par teresa mais c'est l'idée que
la frontière ne serait plus une
frontière entre l'irlande du nord et la
république d'irlande mais au milieu de
la mer et donc le royaume uni ne
resterait pas dans l'union douanière
passe comme un gain pour le pour le
royaume-uni sa souveraineté néanmoins ça
ça mais une frontière qui est maritime
et qui est donc plus qui est davantage
gérable du point de vue politique et qui
ne me menace beaucoup moins les
compromis fragiles en irlande du nord
incertitude politique certainement
depuis 2016 est ce que on constate une
incertitude économique est ce que ça
affecte l'économie du royaume oui ça
l'affect non non j'ai envie de dire on
est un peu en bout de course c'est à
dire que c'est la salle a fait le succès
ultime report l'affect beaucoup moins
que le report qu'il y avait eu au moment
de mars 2019
parce que l'incertitude est moins grande
en ce sens où là on a un accord qui est
pas encore ratifié loin de là mais pour
lesquelles il semble y avoir moins de
moins de frictions que l'accord
précédent et l'autre chose c'est que la
date du break site sans accord aurait dû
être dans une semaine donc les grandes
compagnies ça sur lesquels se basent les
marchés pour leurs prédictions sont
préparés en fait elles sont préparées à
la pire des solutions dont elles font
trois 3 mois de report ça change pas
grand chose
on s'habitue peu reste pratiquement ce
feuilleton de briggs est le plus beau
donner merci beaucoup